yesterday or rather two days ago um we
kind of explored using the chain rule
with exponential functions right
i did set in the homework some products
and some questions but we didn't have
time to really work through it together
so i'm going to give you a bit of a
guide to that there are a couple of
things that worth pointing out as we go
you can see these four questions here
are the very brief examples that we're
going to all work to through
simultaneously
and if you want if you're going a bit
faster than i am i'm quite happy for you
to go further along just watch out there
are some curveballs that have snuck in
that i will explain as i go but if you
get to them before i do
i won't have told you so just be
watchful for them okay
so the first one you can see there it
says e to the x
minus 1 all cubed so what we're going to
do is differentiate this so i'm going to
put a d on dx out the front and what
that indicates is whatever you're about
to see we're going to differentiate it
we're going to find its derivative okay
now i'm using this example it's
relatively simple to point out that
i keep on getting confused about days in
wednesday's lesson i showed you this
very formal long way of writing
using the chain rule with this some of
you might remember i will sneak it down
here
this was the really long way of writing
it whenever we wanted to find d y on dx
we had to introduce
u as our substitution we said this
would let us find d y on d u
and then there was this other derivative
d u on dx and then things would cancel
and we would get the derivative we
wanted right
and that's why this is called chain rule
there's a chain of derivatives that kind
of cancel out nicely okay now this is
the kind of proper way to do it but as
you've probably noticed
it's a bit long like it's just a lot of
stuff to write so when you are
comfortable you can do the same rule
without using all of the notation so let
me show you how it's going to work
i'm going to look at this and i'm going
to in my mind think what's you
what would be the appropriate you in
here
if i were to say like go through do that
long working i my first line of work
might be let u equal and i'm going to
choose something
in here any suggestions
[Applause]
hmm
[Music]
now remember oh yeah michael do you want
to give another
do into the sometimes minus one
okay so this e to the x minus one in
brackets that you just mentioned right
this is a function all by itself
and then we're doing something else to
that we're cubing it so remember it's
what we call the function
of a function okay so this would be my u
however we don't need to say that it is
because all we're going to do is
differentiate that thing with respect to
x which i actually think you guys
already know how to do
what is the derivative of this inside
bit the derivative of e to the x is
e to the x
and the derivative of negative one is
zero so i can just leave it i'm done
there is my d u on dx right and then
when i multiply by is the d y on d u
that's the outside part so i would think
of that as u
cubed when something is cubed you
differentiate it by saying you've
actually done it earlier today right
you bring the power at the front and you
reduce it by one right three u squared
except in this case that's my u
so i'm going to write this three
listen for it
u it's just a very very long u
and then
squared
i'm done i mean yeah you could write the
three out the front if you really wanted
okay but this is fine the whole thing is
finished so you can see it's a lot more
concise than writing all of this stuff
out this is like four or five lines the
catch is if it's not on the paper you've
got to retain it in your head and for me
it's a little bit like when i'm packing
a suitcase and i'm going traveling has
anyone here ever gone pack their
suitcase
pre-pandemic and then they've forgotten
some object that they obviously know you
use all the time like your towel or your
toothbrush like you know to bring your
toothbrush why did you forget
answer you had a lot of stuff in your
head and you just like that thing just
dropped off the bottom okay if this is
something which is too much to keep in
your head
do this
but otherwise if you're quite
comfortable like that was a ton faster
right it's like twice as fast just to
write it okay so if you're comfortable
just go there
let's have a look at question two
similar deal i wonder if we can manage
it we're going to differentiate what did
i give you e to the power of what
7x squared plus x sorry i just can't the
angle's a bit funny so i can't read it
let's see if we can do this again
without writing our long notation right
again i'm looking for a u
what might be the u in this case
yeah fantastic josh it's that 7x squared
plus x is all that stuff
in the index again it's a function
of a function so you're just trying to
identify the whole piece
and i'm going to do just like i did
before i'll have to differentiate this
bit and then differentiate the whole
thing can we differentiate 7x squared
plus x i think we can right what's the
first term going to be
14x i've done this before the x is going
to become
plus 1.
so there's the du on dx
and now i've got e to the power of u
it's just this is my new u
what happens when you differentiate e to
the power of something
it stays the same no change okay so
therefore this thing is just going to be
that no change so i'll write it again
e to the power of 7 x squared plus x
and that's it
like wow mom a whole single line of
working that's it okay so if you're
comfortable doing this you get a massive
time advantage if you can retain it in
your head it's too much do this until
you feel comfortable okay
all right i'm actually going to skip
over three for the sake of time i'm just
going to go straight to four
if you have a go at three and it's like
puzzling you i'm happy to i'll do it on
the board if you like but i want to
highlight a particular lesson in
question four
um
what's your name again you mentioned you
did this what if you what's your name
again
i've asked abbas did this right and this
is actually i said i was going to come
back to this one of us did was he
reframed a question
that used the quotient rule so he didn't
have to use the quotient rule yeah now i
want you to have a look at question four
as i write it on the board in a second i
want you to think about how we can pull
a similar kind of trick to what abbas
did right it looks like a quotient you
can differentiate this with the quotient
rule but i can reframe it so that i
don't need to and unlike here where i
think we concluded pretty much the same
amount of work this one's going to be a
huge time saving so give me a moment to
write it down and i wonder if anyone can
tell me
what might be a way
oh is it plus one it is
that we can rewrite this
so i can avoid the quotient rule any
suggestions
all right what do you reckon
okay very good so this is all one big
fraction at the moment right but i
actually can just slice it right down
the middle do this with me right now you
can see it's got a common denominator e
to the x so in fact i can just say hey
let's view this these two bits on the
numerator let's view them as two
separate fractions with the same
denominator so in fact i'm just going to
write that twice
e to the x
and then e to the x okay now to me in
the first instance it's like that looks
like it's worse not better but it is
better
because say this first fraction i can
simplify that it doesn't have to be a
fraction at all think about your index
laws
e to the 3x divided by e to the x
e to the 2x we are subtracting indices
when we're dividing okay
this one here
1 divided by e to the x this is going to
be a negative index isn't it so i would
write that as e to the
negative
x
no quotients i don't need to use the
quotient rule at all but i do need to
differentiate now all i did was reframe
the question so if the derivative
of all of this
is going to be the same as the
derivative
of all of this and i'm going to go term
by term now okay
this one here it's just like the
question we did in question two right
here's my u
2x what's its derivative just 2x
it's going to be just 2.
and then i've got e to the power of
something e to the power of something
just becomes the same thing it doesn't
change
like so
and i'm just gonna keep going here's my
new u it's
negative x when i differentiate that i
get
negative one so i'm going to go minus
and then i do the rest of it e to the
power of something differentiate it
nothing happens
that's it
in much the same way like we did earlier
if you wanted to because they gave it to
us one fraction you could put it back on
common denominators and get one fraction
but i'm actually quite okay with that